For this quiz, I'm going to list some properties, and you should check the box
for the ones that are true for the given operation mode.
So which modes require that E--the encrypt function that we've been using in the black box--
is invertible?
Check this box if Cipher Block Chaining mode requires this,
and check this box if Cipher Feedback Mode requires this.
Which of them require the Initialization Vector to be kept secret?
Can use small message blocks?
Which can provide strong protection against tampering,
so Alice would be able to know if someone had changed values of parts of her file?
And the final one--that the final cipher text depends on all of the blocks in the message.